RONALD SMITH: There's two
subjects left in
the course now.
One is kind of a brief
introduction to some air
pollution issues, and I've
really narrowed that down.
We're just going to pretty much
talk about the two ozone
problems. I'll explain what I
mean by that in just a minute.
And then the last subject of
the course, which will come
after break, will be
renewable energy.
We'll look at how environment
and energy connect together.
So if you go on the EPA website,
they've got a list of
all the different air pollutants
that they are
concerned about, and this is
roughly their list. I've
combined a couple of things,
but this is roughly their
list. It's a big list. And, of
course, every one of these
kind of has its own story,
its own sources.
The way it moves around in the
atmosphere, the way chemical
reactions may change these
quantities in the atmosphere,
and the way they impact human
health are all different.
So we can't possibly treat that
complex subject in just a
couple of lectures.
But I just wanted to make a
couple of comments about this.
In general, this is what EPA is
concerned about, and things
are getting better.
So, for example, if you plot
some of these emissions I'm
sorry, concentrations on a
relative scale, so this isn't
an absolute scale, they're just
calling everything in
1980 they're giving us a value
of 100, and then plotting
these quantities as they've
changed since the year 1980.
So they've got nitrous oxide,
sulfur dioxide, carbon
monoxide, and lead.
So I think you know some of
these stories, right?
So they took the lead out of
gasoline, so they're no longer
getting tailpipe emissions
of lead.
They've put SO2 scrubbers on
about half of the coal-fired
power plants around the country,
so that's been
decreasing.
And they've instituted this
program of checking your car
to be sure you are within
emission standards.
So the manufacturers have been
asked to improve the vehicles
in terms of how they emit NO2
and CO, and then you are
required at least I am required
here in Connecticut
to occasionally get my car
tested to see whether I'm with
emission standards.
So the combination of these
different activities have
brought generally the
concentrations of these
quantities down.
And if we can thank someone,
it's basically, back in 1970,
two important things happened.
The Clean Air Act was enacted,
and the EPA was founded.
And I was doing some YouTube
googling the other day, and I
found a celebration that took
place last year, celebrating
the 40th anniversary of
the Clean Air Act.
And they were telling stories
about the formation and the
politics involved.
And it was rather amazing,
because the Clean Air Act,
which was a very powerful piece
of legislation, actually
passed the House and the
Senate by very strong
majorities, like 90%.
In other words, both parties,
Republicans and Democrats,
voted strongly for this issue.
And in fact, in 1990 when they
enacted some changes
strengthening certain areas of
the Clean Air Act, again both
parties voted strongly
in favor of it.
Now that would never happen.
It would never even
come close.
You couldn't get anything
changed on this at the moment,
except possibly pulling back on
some of these regulations.
So it's worth just thinking
briefly about the history of
this and the real
impact it's had.
Now, OK, so these aren't Some
of these reductions are only
by half and so on.
And you'd like to have much
stronger reductions that that.
But still, it's a remarkable
example of how scientists can
identify a problem, work out the
causes of the problem, and
then the legislature can react
to that and make some laws
that help the situation in the
long run over decades.
It's nice to know that
that's possible or
at least was possible.
This SO2 thing is big because
that leads to acid rain.
The SO2 is emitted
from smokestacks.
Coal has sulfur in it, so
when you burn coal,
you oxidize the sulfur.
You get SO2.
That goes into the atmosphere.
Some of it forms small particles
that get caught up
in raindrops and rained out.
But having SO2 dissolved in your
raindrop makes that water
acid, which has a big impact on
the organisms and the soils
and the rivers.
And so we've seen actually a
rather dramatic improvement in
the acidity of rainfall, not
shown on that last graph.
Well, that last graph showed
the SO2, but if you look at
the acidity of rain that falls
from the sky, that, too, has
gotten less acidic over the
last 20 or 30 years.
So that's another side of that
general success story.
But what we're going to do here
in this course is just
look at these two problems, the
two ozone problems. Ozone
in the troposphere, especially
in the boundary layer of the
Earth, that is related to
this problem called
photochemical smog.
It's an air pollution problem.
And then the other problem
is stratospheric ozone.
And the problems here are
different in their chemistry,
different in the way they
interact with the atmosphere,
and they're also different in
the most fundamental way.
We've got too much ozone in
photochemical smog, and we're
worried about having too
little ozone in the
stratospheric ozone layer.
So these are different in many
respects even though they all
relate to the same molecule,
O3 ozone.
That's going to be the focus of
both of these discussions.
Stop me if you have questions.
So a few things you have
to know about ozone,
it's formula is O3.
It's just like the oxygen that
you're breathing in.
That's O2.
But this has one more
oxygen atom attached
to it so it's O3.
It's molecular weight then,
instead of being 32, is 48.
It does obey the Perfect
Gas Law.
It is a strong oxidant,
however, much
stronger than O2.
If you put ozone next to some
organic substrate, it will
immediately attack that and try
to oxidize the substance
that it's touching.
It also has important radiative
properties.
It's a greenhouse gas.
It can absorb and emit
infrared radiation.
That's not surprising because
it has a dihedral structure,
oxygen-oxygen-oxygen.
So as it vibrates,
it can absorb and
emit long-wave radiation.
In addition, though, it
emits--it can absorb
ultraviolet radiation, much
shorter wavelength.
It does that by pushing
electrons up and
down in their orbitals.
And these are both
important for us.
Lifetime in the troposphere
is typically pretty
short, hours to days.
Lifetime in the stratosphere
is quite a
bit longer than that.
Usually it's in years.
I'll be defining something
called the Dobson unit, which
is the way we measure the total
amount of ozone in a
column, going all the way
up and down through the
atmosphere.
It's one of the common ways
that we talk to each other
about how much ozone is
in the atmosphere.
And as I've indicated, in the
troposphere, we're interested
in photochemical smog.
In the boundary layer and the
stratosphere, we're interested
in the ozone layer.
So if you plot the amount of
ozone in the atmosphere versus
altitude, the altitude scale
is in kilometers.
Now, this unit here
is a milliPascals.
So what I've plotted is the
partial pressure of ozone.
You know, when you have a
mixture of gases, every type
of molecule contributes
something to the total
pressure of the gas.
So this is the amount that
the ozone mixed into the
atmosphere contributes to
pressure, but it's a small
amount, so we're representing it
in milliPascals, that is, a
thousandths of a Pascal.
And so you see a little elevated
ozone in the first
kilometer or so of the
atmosphere, and that's the
subject of one of the
discussions today.
And then, of course, you get
this rather large peak in
ozone concentration up
in the stratosphere.
Peaked somewhere between 20 and
30 kilometers, that's the
ozone layer.
Questions on that?
STUDENT: What accounts
for that peak?
PROFESSOR: Well, so there's a
formation process
going up there that involves
ultraviolet--
I'll talk about this later,
but I'll give you
a preview of it.
There's ultraviolet radiation
coming from the sun that will
dissociate a regular
oxygen molecule.
So you start with an O2.
You break it into O's, and then
it'll recombine in some
cases as two O3 molecules.
Usually that's short lived,
but when I get to that
section, I'll talk about how
it recycles, but then goes
back to ozone.
But it has to do with
ultraviolet light being able
to reach those elevations.
It's a bit complicated because
ozone--ultraviolet light is
also involved in its
destruction.
So we're going to have to take a
careful look at that when we
get to that point.
So for the moment, we're
going to focus on this
tropospheric problem.
So we're going to be looking at
this only for probably the
rest of today's lecture.
So some of the factors that are
involved in photochemical
smog are the amount of oxides
of nitrogen being emitted.
That's mostly NO and NO2, and
they abbreviate that by
calling it NOx.
In other words, you can put
a 1 or a 2 in there.
There's also an abbreviation
VOC, which is
Volatile Organic Compounds.
It's like when you have a can
of gasoline and some of it
evaporates into the atmosphere,
that would be an
example of a volatile
organic compound.
Organic, you know, means
it has carbon in it.
Volatile means it likes to go
into the gaseous state.
So a good example of that would
be gas evaporating from
your tank and going into
the atmosphere.
Sometimes you see RH, and this
is confusing, because we've
been using that almost
universally until now to mean
relative humidity.
But in this business, sometimes
RH is used to
represent Reactive
Hydrocarbons.
And in that way, it's almost
synonymous with volatile
organic compounds.
The presence of an elevated
inversion is going to be
important because we want to
know whether these emissions,
the NOx and the VOC emissions,
are going to be trapped and
will be concentrated, or whether
they will be diluted
by mixing into large portions
of the atmosphere.
If there's a valley geometry,
that's important, too, because
that also comes into the
question of dilution.
And then, as we will see,
sunlight and warmth will be a
factor because there are certain
chemical reactions
that convert one form of
pollutant to another.
And those typically require
sunlight and warmth in order
for those chemical reactions
to take place.
So if you're trying to
understand why a particular
part of the world has an air
pollution problem, like the LA
Basin, or Santiago, Chile, or
Mexico City, it's these five
factors that you want to look at
that will determine why one
region has an air pollution
problem and
another region may not.
It'll have to do with
those things.
We'll talk a lot more about
those in just a moment.
So Mexico City, for example,
typically has
this kind of haze.
Now, looking at this, you
wouldn't know, I guess,
whether that is just a fog, a
radiation fog, for example,
except it's usually in the
Mexico City area, which is in
kind of a big basin, it's
usually not found so much in
other basins.
In other words, so it's not
just the fact that it's
low-lying land, and there's a
clear sky, and you're getting
radiation fog.
It has to do with these
emissions of VOCs and NOxs
that are then reacting
to cause smog.
Now, smog is a contraction
of smoke and fog.
But today, it's used to work
to mean a kind of air
pollution with a certain
chemistry going on to cause
that particular combination of
particles and gases that are
mixed in there together.
Beijing has a similar problem,
as do many other
cities around the world.
Now, EPA sets limits on ozone
concentrations, ozone as a gas
now in the atmosphere.
And these have changed from time
to time, but I believe
these are the current values.
There's a one-hour standard and
an eight-hour standard.
So if you have an average ozone
concentration of greater
than 0.12 parts per million by
volume for an hour, you are in
exceedance of the one-hour
standard for ozone set by EPA.
Even if you never reach that
value, but if the average over
an eight-hour period is greater
than 0.01 parts per
million by volume, you're also
in exceedance of EPA standard.
Yes?
STUDENT: This is emission
by a plant or by a car?
PROFESSOR: No, this is
concentration.
So this is measured in
the atmosphere as now
what's being emitted.
As we'll see in a moment,
nothing emits ozone.
So this certainly could not
be an emission standard.
Ozone is created in the
atmosphere from
other chemical emissions.
So this is purely a
concentration standard.
So for example, the
EPA in Connecticut
would set up a station.
There used to be one here
in Connecticut.
I don't know if it's still here,
and a few others around
the state, where they measure
ozone concentration in the
atmosphere hourly.
And they determine whether or
not they are approaching or
exceeding these EPA standards.
Question?
STUDENT: So since it's not like
one body that's creating
this, what happens
when it exceeds?
How does the city or the
region within it
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we'll
talk about
that a little bit.
But you can imagine it's
confusing because you cannot
track this down often to
a single polluter.
It's kind of a regional thing.
Now, I've given this EPA
standard to you, and they give
it to you in two different
units.
And because we are familiar
with such things in this
course, I wanted to spend a few
minutes just guaranteeing
that you can work with both
of those types of units.
These are important numbers.
So that's a part per million by
volume, so that is a ratio
of the number of molecules.
That would be well, let me
multiply that by 1,000.
That would be one, two, three.
That would be 120 molecules of
ozone for every billion,
because I multiplied by
that for every billion
molecules of air.
Or if you prefer it this way,
it's about 0.1 it's hard to
split up a molecule.
That's why it's hard to say it
this way, but 0.12 molecules
of ozone for every million
molecules of air, OK?
So that's in the form
of a mixing ratio
by number of molecules.
This is a mass density.
You'll recognize that unit.
Except instead of being
kilograms per cubic meter,
it's micrograms. A microgram
is 10 to the
minus 6 of a gram.
So that's a pretty small mass
density, but that is again a
quantity that you are used
to dealing with.
So I want you to
remember that.
I'll do some calculations for
you on the next slide.
And we can do a similar check to
be sure that these numbers
are consistent.
So on the next slide, I'm going
to check to see if those
two numbers are really the same
because we know how to do
those conversions
in this course.
So a few ozone calculations.
First of all, you remember that
a mixing ratio by mass,
where you're using rho, which
is mass density in forming a
ratio, can be computed if you
know the mixing ratio by
volume, that is, by molecule,
by just multiplying by the
ratio of the molecular weight,
which in this case is 48 for
ozone and 29 for air.
The mixing ratio that I gave you
on the last slide was 0.12
parts per million by volume,
which can be written this way.
And so I'm going to take this
equation and solve it for the
mass density of ozone.
So I'm simply going to bring the
rho AIR over to the other
side and plug in numbers, and
that's the line here.
So you still have the ratio
of molecular weights.
For the mixing ratio by volume,
I put it in here.
And then I put in the density
for air, which is a standard
value we've been using for sea
level density all through the
course, and that's about
1.2 kilograms per
cubic meter of air.
And you can check to be sure
I've done this right.
But when I convert this to
micrograms per cubic meter, I
get 235, which is just what
the EPA claimed was the
equivalent of that.
So that's how you can go back
and forth between these
different measures of
ozone concentration.
Any questions on that?
Let's do one other.
Let's compute the partial
pressure of ozone using the
Perfect Gas Law.
Pressure equals rho RT.
It's the partial pressure of
ozone we're computing, so it's
going to be the mass density of
ozone we're using, the gas
constant for ozone and then the
temperature, whatever that
is, but it has to
be in Kelvin.
The gas constant for ozone is
the universal gas constant
divided by the molecular
weight.
That's 48, so it's 173.2.
And then let's just put
the numbers in here.
From the previous slide, 235.
I've converted this to
kilograms, though, so we get a
10 to the minus 9 in there.
There comes the gas constant
for ozone.
And I've used a typical Earth
temperature of 288, and I get
12 milliPascals for that.
So if the EPA had wanted to
express that limit in partial
pressure, that's the value
they could have used.
So we've seen three different
ways that you can express this
concentration of ozone.
Let me go back to the plot.
This was in milliPascals.
And this author had it about 5,
but the value we computed
is right about there, which is
the same order of magnitude in
units of millipascals.
OK, so who is in exceedance
of this?
And this gives you
a rough idea.
Now, this happens to be an
eight-hour ground-level ozone
standard based on 0.06
or 0.07 ppmv.
And they've got different
levels here.
515 counties violate
the 0.07 standard.
93 additional counties violate
a 0.065 standard, and 42
additional counties
violate the 0.06.
But anyway, you see roughly
where they are.
Some are in Florida.
Those who are going to go
on vacation in Florida,
watch out for this.
It's mostly a summertime
problem, but it's still kind
of summery in Florida.
Quite a bigger problem in the
Northeast, and then, of
course, California happens to be
the worst for a combination
of reasons large population,
dense population, especially
in the cities.
There's a strong inversion
that typically traps
pollutants in Southern
California.
You've got mountains, which can
often trap the pollutants
from moving horizontally.
So it's a combination of things
that brings and you
have a lot of sunlight which
can help with the
conversion to ozone.
So that's roughly how the
exceedances are scattered
around the country.
The damage, of course, comes
when you breathe this in.
It will then attack your throat,
trachea, and lungs.
Basically, it oxidizes organic
tissue, which can really cause
some breathing problems for some
people are more sensitive
than others.
But we can all be influenced
by this.
And therefore, if you're an
athlete, if you're a runner or
something, usually you will
keep yourself aware of the
ozone concentrations and not do
outdoor activities during
periods of time when there's
a high ozone concentration.
Indoor should be OK, because
usually, ozone concentrations
inside a building are
not a problem.
The ozone will react with things
in the walls, destroy
itself, and you don't usually
have much of a problem with
ozone inside a building.
But outside you can, and you'll
want to adjust your
athletic activities
accordingly.
So now, let's look at the
sequence of events that leads
to ozone pollution.
I've taken some slides here
from a nice book by Turco,
Earth Under Siege.
So here's a little
Volkswagen Bug or
something, perking along.
And what's coming out of the
tailpipe is primarily oxides
of nitrogen, reactive
hydrocarbons, and carbon
monoxide.
We're going to call those
primary pollutants because
they are being emitted
directly by
the offending vehicle.
In addition, you've
got the sun.
With ultraviolet radiation, some
chemical reactions are
going to take place to
convert--to produce NO2, some
additional hydrocarbons, and
then later in the day, we're
going to start to
generate these.
But we still have the carbon
monoxide, but now, we're
getting ozone, PAN, which I'll
define in a minute, and that
haze that you see when you look
at the pictures of these
polluted areas.
But this takes some
hours to produce.
And so this would as I'll show
you, this sort of thing would
typically peak in the middle
afternoon after some chemical
reactions have converted the
primary pollutants to these
that we call secondary
pollutants.
I'm going to walk through these
a bit step by step.
First of all, the vehicle
itself will emit these
quantities, depending
on how it's tuned.
So here's an example
fuel-to-air
stoichiometric ratio.
So in the old days, you actually
had a control on the
dashboard where you could lean
the mixture or enrich the
mixture, that is, how much gas
goes in per amount of air into
the cylinder.
Now that's all done
automatically by a computer,
but still it's an important
quantity.
So the fuel to air ratio
is given here.
And you really--you can't
perfectly win this, because if
you try to go for minimum carbon
monoxide emissions,
well, then you're getting more
nitrogen oxides and so on.
But you can see how the relative
quantities of this
may change.
And you're trying to find some
kind of optimum by getting the
proper fuel-to-air
stoichiometric ratio.
And engines have improved
greatly in this regard, and
the catalytic converters
have helped also.
So then if you are to set up a
monitoring station this was
done in Lennox in the
Los Angeles Basin.
I don't know where Lennox is.
Anybody from LA?
Must be some little suburb or
something of Los Angeles.
What's plotted here is the
carbon monoxide concentration
parts per million by volume
for both plots.
This goes through a typical day,
a 24-hour day period, and
this goes through
a typical year.
And in addition, they've
got a summer and a
winter curve here.
So we can see immediately that
for CO, there's more of a
problem in the winter
than the summer.
And we see that here, too,
because November, December,
January have higher
CO2 concentrations
than does the summer.
We also see on the 24-hour
clock, we see two peaks.
What are those two
peaks caused by?
STUDENT: Rush hour.
PROFESSOR: Rush hour, exactly.
So this is primarily automobile
emissions, and this
is a primary pollutant.
This was actually coming out of
the tailpipe, so it reacts
to the timing of the morning and
the afternoon rush hour,
so you can actually see that.
Now, what makes the winter worse
than the summer, I'm
guessing, has to do with having
a stronger inversion in
the wintertime.
And that will cause more
trapping of the air, and the
concentrations will build up to
be somewhat greater in the
winter than they do
in the summer.
So this is an example of
a primary pollutant.
Question on that?
Let's go on and look at NO2.
And generally, you can still
see that twice-a-day peak.
It's a little bit weaker.
There's less of a difference
between winter and summer,
because now you've got
a combination of
things going on.
You needed some warmth, which
you have in the summer, to
convert NO to NO2.
And you need sunlight as well.
But then in summer, you have
a weaker inversion.
So the two things kind of
cancel to give you more
similar behavior between
winter and summer
when it comes NO2.
And now we'll do ozone, which is
really the thing we're most
concerned about.
Ozone looks quite different
than the other.
Now, it has a summertime maximum
and a mid afternoon,
so that peaks around 1 or 2 or
3 o'clock in the afternoon.
So we're not seeing the rush
hour here because those
primary pollutants hang around
for several hours as chemical
reactions driven by the sun and
driven by the temperature
convert them to the
ozone product.
And therefore, this is more
dependent on those chemical
conversion reactions than on
the timing of the emissions
themselves from the
rush hour traffic.
And look how peaked in
the summer it is.
That means that again this
conversion is the big deal,
not the trapping by the--
I say it wrong?
Not the inversion so much,
which is stronger in the
wintertime, but rather the
conversion from primary to
secondary pollutants are
controlling the summertime
maximum here.
So if you're an athlete, and
you get up in the morning,
that's great.
Do your run right then before,
say, 8 or 9 o'clock.
If you're too lazy to get up
that early, then I think you'd
better skip it until you get to
around, well, 8 o'clock in
the evening, something like
this, or even 9 o'clock.
Then go out and do your run.
Otherwise, do your exercise
inside if you're in one of
these locations.
Questions on this?
So this summarizes a
little bit of that.
The primary pollutants
tend to peak in the
early part of the day.
The secondary pollutions peak
in the later part of the day
because of the time for
those conversion
reactions to take place.
So an important part of the
argument that I just gave you
was this distinction between
primary pollutants and
secondary pollutants.
Primary pollutants are the ones
that are emitted directly.
Secondary pollutants are the
ones that are produced later
on by chemical reactions going
on in the Earth's atmosphere.
So be sure you've got
a clear distinction
between those two things.
Now, this has been
well studied.
And this rather clever diagram
was published a couple of
decades ago that has been very
helpful in allowing city
managers to reduce ozone
concentrations.
So what's plotted on this
diagram, on the x-axis is the
emitted reactive hydrocarbons.
On the y-axis are the emitted
oxides of nitrogen.
Both units are kilograms
per square kilometer.
I don't know what the time
frame on that is.
Perhaps it's per day
or per year.
I don't know.
And then contoured on here
is the resultant ozone
concentration in the same units
we've been using, parts
per million by volume.
So you'll recognize that as the
one-hour standard, that
curve there, and that as the
12-hour standard from the--
from the EPA.
So basically, we want our city
or town to be somewhere in the
periphery of this diagram,
not in this high ozone
concentration in the
upper right.
What this diagram shows you is
that you've got two different
control strategies.
You can reduce the number of
NOx emissions, which will
bring you down on the curve, or
you can reduce the amount
of hydrocarbon emissions, which
will bring you to the
left of the curve.
Now, if you are here, it's not
going to do you much good to
reduce the hydrocarbon emissions
because you're going
to move that way on the curve,
and you're going to have about
the same ozone concentrations.
But if you reduce NOx emissions,
you can bring
yourself down to a lower
ozone concentration.
Conversely, if you're over here,
your strategy should
involve hydrocarbon emissions,
not so much NO emissions.
So this is a kind of a road
map for air pollution
districts to figure out where
to put their effort in
reducing emissions.
Questions on this?
But they've been doing this.
This is I think for LA, but it's
in relative units, so I
can't say much about
the units here.
But it's 1965 to about 2005,
and you see the carbon
monoxide emissions have
been decreasing.
The volatile organic compounds
have been decreasing, and the
NOx have been increasing.
So these cities have worked
very hard to reduce the
sources of this, both from
automobiles and from other
industrial sources.
Here in Connecticut,
for example,
we've had some success.
This is the Connecticut one-hour
and eight-hour ozone
exceedances in units of days.
So how many days a year do you
have an ozone exceedance?
The data goes back to 1974.
At that point, they only
had the which one
is the lower one?
That would be the
STUDENT: One hour.
PROFESSOR: The one hour.
Yeah, the one-hour exceedance.
And that was about if I average
this out, that was
about 50 days a year where you'd
have an ozone exceedance
in Connecticut.
This data ends in 2004, but they
were down to about five
on average, about five days
per year with an ozone
exceedance.
Now, they had the eight-hour
exceedance, where
you get more typically.
Although it's an average over
a longer period of time, it
has a lower threshold, so you
get more exceedances.
But that, too, has dropped over
time because of pollution
controls on the primary
pollutants.
Questions on that?
So this can be done and has been
done, but you know, it
could be better as well.
So that is that.
I don't usually end
this early, but I
think I will today.
So next time we will do the
other ozone problem.
We'll do the stratospheric
ozone problem.
So there is a little section on
your book on this, so read
ahead for that one.